merci il y aura près de 250 mille
chômeurs de plus d'ici la fin du mois
douce et michel rocard en personne qui a
fait cette déclaration se mettent à
l'issue du conseil des ministres le
premier ministre met directement en
cause le dispositif mis en place par le
précédent gouvernement
déclaration d'autant plus remarqué
qu'elle intervient à la veille des
premières rencontres entre le
gouvernement précisément et les
syndicats véronique auger coup de poing
sur la table du premier ministre et
pourtant lindt et vient d'annoncer une
toute petite augmentation du chômage
pour avril +0 1% en fait il s'agit de la
fin du panier avant la chute d'ici au
mois d'août il y aura 250 mille
demandeurs d'emplois en plus la france
comptera deux millions sept cent
cinquante mille chômeurs un record vous
pourquoi tel bond en avant parce que
l'ensemble du dispositif de stages du
coup autre moyen de traitement social du
chômage s'est arrêté net il ya trois
semaines désormais les sorties de stage
ne seront plus compensés par les
rentrées et statistiques vont bondir et
michel rocard accuse pour lui il ne
s'agit pas d'un prévoyance il me faut
dire une chose grave
l'ensemble des dispositifs d'accueil des
chômeurs et notamment des jeunes
chômeurs en complément de formation
quelle qu'en soit la forme stage
d'insertion dans la vie professionnelle
travaux d'utilité collective toute forme
de stage a été organisé par le
gouvernement qui nous précédaient
précédait le mien d'une façon telle que
plus de 200000 probablement près de
250000 personnes vont se trouver
mécaniquement inévitablement chômeurs
supplémentaires pendant les mois de
juillet et d'août parce que toutes les
procédures prennent fin nous n'éviterons
pas une augmentation pendant l'été elle
et elle était sans doute voulu j'ai
regret de le dire aussi fermement
l'ancien gouvernement ne va pas tarder à
réagir à ces attaques en attendant
l'actuel premier ministre a annoncé que
deux nouveaux types de stages des
marettes en septembre mais ils ne
permettront probablement pas de
rattraper le retard et de faire retomber
les chiffres en dessous de 2 millions
700 mille chômeurs d'ici la fin de
l'année oui sachez encore